happy Valentine's Day weekend looking
for something to watch with your BAE we
got you covered
million theaters this weekend happy
deathday to you Elita battle angel and
isn't it romantic what will you see this
is your weekend ticket
[Music]
it's a reset when you died right yeah I
might be able to help with that I died
11 times happy death a tu is in theaters
this weekend happy deathday tu is in
theaters this weekend happy deathday tu
is in theaters this weekend that's art
happy deathday to you is the slasher
horror sequel to the original 2017
Groundhog's Day and happy death day and
the main character tree finds herself
yet again back in the murder repeating
time whoo
okay yeah I folded your pants I don't
believe this time around the original
killer is dead tree discovers her
friends are all so caught up in the
mayhem and they must all work together
to break the loop if you don't be set
the day and try again they're dead for
good aren't they so I'm gonna have to
die over and over again to save all of
you I mean I guess you could just reset
the day yourself genius idea this movies
for you if you like the original happy
deathday you're a fan of the slasher
genre or you believe in Valentine's Day
inspired second champions
[Music]
[Applause]
also out this weekend is a leta battle
angel take a manga based cyberpunk
screenplay written by avatars James
Cameron throw on the Western action
master Robert Rodriguez to direct and
mixing the likes of Christoph Waltz
Jennifer Connelly and Maher Sheela Ali
and what do you get
sweet post-apocalyptic machine battles
and a cool story about a disembodied
core Aleta with no memory who is given a
new body oh and guess what turns out she
has a super awesome past which should be
obvious because she's a disembodied core
that has machine battles duh this movies
for you if you like sci-fi action
stories you're in a post-apocalyptic
futuristic themes or your disembodied
core 9-1-1 what's your emergency
someone's broken into my apartment and
they've taken everything and replace it
all with much nicer stuff so that I am
finally out this weekend isn't it
romantic this super meta romantic
romantic comedy comedy stars rebel
Wilson Liam Hemsworth and Adam Devine
frustrated with love Natalie played by
rebel Wilson it's tired of Hollywood's
portrayal of romance
all those maybes allows that terrible
pop songs I think people would have an
easier time seeing you if you were a
little more open okay
I'm Jack unfortunately for her after a
head injury she wakes up and finds that
she herself is in a romantic comedy
you're caught the beguiling aren't you
are you feeling what I'm feeling no
bummer
this movie is for you if you like
rom-coms you like like rom-coms or you
might even say you're in like with
rom-coms that is your Valentine's Day
weekend ticket hopefully there's
something for you and your BAE and check
back next week for another lesson in
dragon training
[Music]